[Music]
having a child go from healthy and
active to almost not being able to
breathe it is one of the harsh realities
some parents are facing now as their
children are battling RSV Victoria Saha
talking with a parent whose baby is in
the hospital with the virus right now
Victoria
yeah we've been reporting about the rise
of RSV also known as respiratory sync
social virus for a while and like many
of you at home this parent was also
watching the headlines but never thought
he would be the parent with the child
struggling to breathe
it was so fast you can't really
understand what was happening John
trainer's 10-month-old son Elliot is in
the Pediatric ICU at UMC this poor kid
who like 48 Hours four was playing with
his brothers and crawling around and all
of a sudden you're talking about how to
get him to breathe what started off as
some sniffles Thursday quickly escalated
into something much worse from Saturday
it was struggling to even sit up on the
couch struggling to Open Eyes uh in the
morning trainer says that they took baby
Elliott to Urgent Care from there X-rays
showed he had pneumonia and later
learned Elliott contracted RSV he needed
to be rushed to the ER in an ambulance
with the case of respiratory illnesses
On The Rise it was a five hour wait to
even get a room in your store pediatric
icu's in the valley if they're all fully
out of California Trina and his wife now
taking turns to be by Elliot's side 24
7. that's what we do all night we just
stare at this little screen reducing
here and you worry about every alarm
that goes off doctors at first thought
Elliot's condition required intubation
but they opted to sedate him and give
him as much oxygen as possible hoping
his little body can fight on its own
according to Southern Nevada Health
District there have been 150 reported
cases of RSV in September but those
numbers can always increase as soon as
additional data is reported as for baby
Elliott there is good news he is now off
the full oxygen mask and now in a nose
mask he is making progress but isn't out
of the woods just yet David Victoria
thank you of course we wish him well
since the holidays are around the corner
there are some things that you can do to
prevent the spread of RSV in your
household doctors say before you gather
you want to make sure your child is of
course up to date on all those routine
vaccinations including covid and the flu
wash and sanitize any High touch surface
areas like counters and bathrooms and of
course eat fresh fruits and vegetables